Trascrizione: Carlotta Serafini
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
La parola Dio ha spesso alimentato
conflitti, guerre, violenza.
Altre volte anche attivato
stati d'animo di paura e di angoscia.
Come pure non raramente ha portato
a evadere dalla concretezza della realtà.
La vicenda umana di Gesù di Nazareth
racconta di un Dio capovolto,
un Dio che frantuma
il concetto di onnipotenza
e lo riorganizza attorno
alla dimensione della mitezza.
E quando dico mitezza
intendo quello stato d'essere
per cui uno gioisce
del fatto che esistono gli altri.
Quello stato di vita,
quella predisposizione
a far sì che l'altro viva
che l'altro esista, addirittura
che l'altro abbia più spazio di me,
che grazie all'altro, io esisto.
E senza l'altro non c'è niente di me
e senza l'altro mi disintegro.
E allora, dentro
la dimensione della mitezza,
è chiaro che l'altro
è un compagno di viaggio
mai un competitor.
È un amico e non un avversario.
Alla luce di questa riorganizzazione
del concetto di onnipotenza
come mitezza, come gioia per l'esistere,
ecco che allora anche il credere
nel Dio di Gesù di Nazareth
è un'operazione estremamente esistenziale,
un'operazione
che coinvolge la vita, la storia.
È un atto di concretezza
che ha il suo DNA,
la sua struttura portante
attorno alla dimensione dell'abbassarsi.
Per cui credere incredibilmente è un FARE,
è un portarsi sul terreno dell'altro,
è un portarsi al livello dell'altro,
è un rendersi uguali.
E l'operazione più difficile
è proprio rendersi uguali,
è portarsi sul terreno dell'altro
con la gioia di sentire
che l'altro è la mia adrenalina,
è la mia forza, è la mia vita.
E concretamente
diamo un nome a questo abbassarsi:
vuol dire attivare
la dimensione dell'ascoltare,
del dialogare, della solidarietà;
che non vanno declinate però
come un impegno etico,
come un impegno per far del bene,
ma vanno attivate
come condizione esistenziale,
per cui l'abbassarsi a livello dell'altro,
gioire per l'esistenza dell'altro
non è un'operazione etica di buon cuore,
è la condizione
per poter gustarsi la vita.
Perché vedete, il laghetto di Narciso
è un laghetto che custodisce la morte.
Quando l'Ego ingrandisce se stesso,
si dilata, a un certo punto sente
soltanto l'eco della propria parola,
l'eco delle proprie sensazioni,
l'eco delle proprie performance.
Ed è terribile, quando
l'unica parola che ti ritorna è la tua,
quando l'unica sensazione è la tua,
quando l'unica operazione legittima
è quella che fai tu.
È terribile.
E quindi quando l'Ego diventa eco,
l'Ego divora se stesso,
implode e si devasta, si frantuma.
E allora mi piace pensare
che l'esperienza credente
è una profonda operazione
di umanizzazione,
è un'operazione benessere,
un'operazione benessere.
Il rischio grande è di intraprendere
l'esperienza credente
come un'operazione etica.
Non è etica.
È operazione di benessere.
È scoperta della grande potenzialità
che ha il mio lasciarmi ferire
dal volto dell'altro
e per quanto l'altro possa ferirmi,
meglio ferito dall'altro che
distrutto dal laghetto di Narciso,
dove ci sono io, io,
io e la mia solitudine
io e la mia angoscia,
io e la mia morte.
E allora, alla luce di tutto questo,
mi piace pensare al divino,
quello narrato dalla vicenda concreta,
umana, storica di Gesù di Nazareth
come a un umano
che raggiunge il suo vertice.
Per cui per me divino è
quando l'umano si fa perdono,
si fa amore per il nemico,
si fa gratuità assoluta.
Quando l'umano addirittura riesce
a mettere in gioco perfino l'esistenza,
quell'umano per me è il divino.
Quindi non c'è più un'opposizione
tra umano e divino
come siamo soliti pensare.
Dire umano è dire
l'opposto del divino?
No. Dire umano è dire,
è parlare di divino.
C'è una soluzione continua
tra umano e divino,
c'è uno scambio, un interagire continuo,
per cui dentro il divino io trovo l'umano,
dentro l'umano trovo il divino.
Per cui risalendo l'umano arrivo al divino
e se trovo il divino scendo all'umano.
A me piace tantissimo
questa prospettiva
di ridefinizione del volto di Dio
attorno alla categoria dell'umano.
Mi piace tantissimo
pensare a questa idea della mitezza
come forza, come energia.
Mi piace tantissimo
pensare che l'esodo da me,
il lasciarmi incontrare dagli occhi,
dalle mani, dal volto dell'altro
non è un'operazione che mi impoverisce,
ma che mi arricchisce.
E veramente mi pare
di una straordinaria attualità
percepire che questo Dio
dà qualità all'umano,
dà spessore all'umano,
rende l'umano profondamente interessante,
e profondamente vincente.
E allora vorrei proprio
spezzare una lancia,
anche per una ridefinizione,
passando per questa realtà
dell'umanità di Gesù,
una ridefinizione anche nel concetto
proprio del credere,
dove il credere non è un'operazione
che coinvolge la dimensione intellettiva,
non è una operazione
che coinvolge la dimensione emotiva.
Ma è un FARE, è un fidarsi.
È un fidarsi dell'operazione
dell'affidarsi al volto dell'altro,
riconoscendo che
quel volto è la mia forza,
con Lévinas tornino i volti
ad abitare la vita,
tornino i volti a definirmi,
perché io sono l'altro.
In questa prospettiva
vorrei riprendere anche
il fatto che viene verificata
la vita del credente,
anche a livello evangelico,
da una pagina che io dico
una pagina estremamente laica,
estremamente poco religiosa,
come è la pagina di Matteo 25:
"Avevo fame e mi hai dato da mangiare,
avevo sete mi hai dato da bere".
Questa pagina definisce il credere
sul terreno proprio dell'esistenza,
sul terreno della storia,
della concretezza della storia.
E a me è veramente intriga molto
pensare un Dio che è uscito da sé,
si è portato al mio livello
ha frequentato il mio terreno,
si è inabissato nel mio terreno
in tutte le sue dimensioni
e ha bisogno di interagire con me.
Questa è l'altra grande scoperta e novità,
un Dio che ha bisogno
di interagire con me.
La categoria del bisogno normalmente
noi non la portiamo sul terreno di Dio,
ma noi possiamo portarla
tranquillamente sul terreno di Dio
perché quando si tratta dell'amare,
l'amare ha nel riferimento all'altro
il suo elemento decisivo e portante.
Il bisogno di chi ama non è indigenza,
non è povertà, non è inadeguatezza.
Il bisogno di chi ama è forza sopraffina,
perché quando io dico "ho bisogno di te"
non faccio un'affermazione di debolezza,
ma faccio un'affermazione
estremamente di potenza e di forza.
Ed è bellissimo pensare
che il Dio cristiano non si vergogna
di dire "io ho bisogno".
Perché è il Dio dell'amore,
è il Dio dell'uscita, il Dio dell'esodo.
E per me amare vuol dire questo,
portarsi sul terreno dell'altro,
farlo vivere e sentire
che, se vive lui, esisto.
Viceversa, se cancello lui,
cancello anche me.
E allora, mi pare
estremamente interessante
invitarvi a entrare in questa dimensione
della prospettiva dell'umano
di Gesù di Nazareth.
Perché a questo punto lo posso dire,
sei umano se esci,
sei umano se ti rendi vulnerabile,
sei umano se hai il coraggio
di lasciarti ferire,
di ripartire dopo una ferita,
sei umano se non ti fa paura
lasciarti ferire.
Non sei più umano,
cominci a implodere,
cominci a disgregarti.
Quando la paura ti attanaglia,
l'unica prospettiva che ti resta
è quella di ingrandire te stesso.
L'unica prospettiva che ti resta
è quella della performance,
di affidarti alla performance,
alla giocata solitaria, a te stesso.
E quando uno è affidato a se stesso
è morto, non è vivo.
Penso, forse, di aver dato
un piccolo contributo a ripensare Dio.
È un piccolissimo assaggio,
un piccolissimo contributo
per cui son contento
del mio Dio capovolto,
spero che lo possano incontrare
anche altri e magari, su questo terreno,
ri-iniziare un discorso di umanizzazione
di cui abbiamo estremo bisogno.
Grazie.
(Applausi)